let's do the workshop so the first talk
in this session I wish I will be talking
about is excitation recent work with
round robin for women for complexity and
that's really something in this document
but those what so classically apply
thank you so this will be mostly a talk
about lower bounds this is a no
conspiration of beekeeping phenomena
hierarchy joint walk with us and this is
a beautiful illustration I was drawn by
my mother in this tried to illustrate an
Oracle we're sort of click on this
button and it gives you like an answer
so let's start with recalling some of
the favorite complexity classes so we
have P we have NP Co NT
and all of these seats inside what is
known as the polynomial Iraqi which can
be captured by alternating quantifiers
and we will see the exact definition in
the next few slides all these seeds
within P space everything that you can
compute in polynomial space you can also
talk about randomized algorithm one
favorite us is bpp bounded there or this
extends P but we suspect that it
actually equals P however currently we
only know that VPP is inside at least in
this picture inside th and the main
motive any question for this talk is
where does BQ p or bounded arrow quantum
for longer time seats we fill these
pictures so we know that anything that a
randomized algorithm can do a quantum
algorithm can do and we know that bqp
see since I see space so it's somewhere
between DP P and P space but we want to
know more so in particular we want to
know what is the relation of bqp with NP
or with pH we suspect that these two
things are incomparable that there will
be some languages that are in one and
not in the other and vice versa however
we cannot even separate
P from P space right in this picture
it could be still possible everything
equals to P so any separation that we
will try to prove should be in some
relaxed motion and we are very far from
food peace not equal to P space so we
will relax the question okay so we will
talk about Oracle separations indeed the
Oracle separation were known with
respect to bqp so this gives us some
evidence about the relation between the
true classes maybe not the right
evidence but some so in particular this
result that shows that the recent work
over NP is not in big Q P with respect
to this cynical can be thought as saying
that it's highly unlikely is it that
quantum algorithm would solve
np-complete problems or is it that would
would solve this adequate you can base
it on this Oracle separation this
fundamental work of Bernstein buddy
Ronnie that actually introduces bqp also
supposed to prove the bqp stronger than
bt p with respect to an Oracle so there
exists some problem but you can solve in
bqp with artists to this Oracle but you
cannot solve if we build Beaufort is
still the same Oracle this already gives
us some quantum soup superiority or and
you can ask whether it holds for higher
classes so maybe you can do it for NP
and in fact it's correct and you can
even do it for MA so what Ruth showed
the separation between bqp and ma this
was the state-of-the-art we're still
open to show such separation for bqp
versus pH and even bqp vs am something
that sits even lower than the second
level of the hierarchy this is what we
will do in this talk so our main result
will be a separation of D Q P and P H so
let's look at what is pH what is the
polynomial ality
so we said the language isn't in the
polynomial hierarchy if the resistant
constant K and a sequence of quantifiers
there exists Y 1 for all Y 2 so we have
this alternating quantifiers and X is in
the language if we can write this
formula word with this K 1 and then
apply some relay
our which is political computable in its
argument on X and all these ones in
particular you can think of MP is a
version where you have only one
quantifiers there exist okay then you
have a relation on X and the weakness
currently is for all and this sort of
captures both of them and can you can
alternate between the quantifiers
okay so what do we want we want the
relation to be poet on computable and we
want the the strings device would be of
polynomial length in the length of X
what we show our main result we show
that there is an Oracle under which bqp
refer specifics Oracle is not contained
in P H with respect to solving so really
what we do we come up with an Oracle and
a language that can be computed in bqp
with queries to this Oracle but cannot
be computed with pH with queries to this
order in fact the result is stronger
than that and we can allow even super
constant number of alternation and we
can even go for wise which are upset
nearly exponential in X so and we have
some trade-off between these two things
but I will not get into the exact
details here you can just think of case
constant and the sizes of wise is for
long I mean the size of X okay I
mentioned Oracle but actually I will
focus most of my talk on this black box
model or the query model and the reason
that it's enough is it at that box
separation imply Oracle separation so we
can sort of take the separation from
this wall to the Oracle wall and these
are known reductions and what is this
black box model or the query model so
think of your input X is given to you as
a black box and you want to learn some
property of the input what you can do
you can sort of ask this black box
that's what is the value of a specific
coordinate okay so you give it a
coordinate I and it gives you the the
beat of
during this in this location okay if you
want to think of this maybe as a
function you can think of it as like you
give it some input and it gives you some
output okay so when we talk about
deterministic algorithm with respect to
this model this really correspond to the
decision tree model right the decision
tree depths is exactly the number of
queries that we make to this cell or to
these black box in the worst case but we
can also talk about randomized version
non-deterministic version of this model
and in particular we will think of
quantum version of this model this was
studied a lot in the literature what do
I mean by that so instead of just giving
one query register basically I would
give a query the superposition and then
I will get an answer in superposition so
I have a different coefficient for each
of the possible queries and then I get
the value of x I multiplied this
amplitude by by minus one if it was the
minus one and doesn't change it if it
was a plus one okay so this is one way
to define the core model a lot of the
results in quantum computing are
actually presented in this model so you
can present well for searching in this
model period finding okay what is the
analog of of pH is this modal dialogue
of pH and have we mentioned lift already
this morning is AC zero circuit why is
do we have this correspondence so think
of this is a quantifier we can take this
there exist one differ and change
accretion or feeding many many inputs
and we can change that for all with an N
and we need to change the relation so we
can change it with a small DNF so
basically whenever we have an expression
that defines a language in PH we have an
AC zero circuit and the depth will be
really the number of quantifiers
or maybe password okay so really what we
want to show is we want to show some
separation between quantum query
complexity and ic0 circuit and then we
can sort of use the non reduction to
translate them into Oracle separations
okay now I want to move to the
pseudo-random setting so cover mentioned
it and you stopped a lot oh yeah so I
will just go very quickly so on the
right hand side we have a truly random
screen all these coins are fair and
they're independent of one another
each is heads with probability 1/2 Delta
probably off on the left hand side we
have a pseudo-random stream okay so a
strings that look run what I mean by
that I mean that it looks random to the
function f that is operating on the
sequence of beats okay so to be more
precise we serve the distribution in
pseudo-random against the class of
function see if any function is this
class C is a similar expectation under
the distribution D as it has under the
uniform distribution many in some sense
the function cannot tell apart between
the two cases
okay so this beautiful to work show that
for this challenge can you find the
distribution which is pseudo-random for
AC zero but not pseudo-random against
poly log time quantum algorithm and here
it really meaning the blackbox study
okay so the algorithm would work in poly
log time and would make queries to the
input
suppose that you can find such a
distribution they show that you can
translate it into an Oracle separating
between bqp and the polynomial hierarchy
okay and the connection are like I
mentioned like them vaguely at least the
connection between pH and I see zero and
the other connection is just by sort of
pedagogy okay so it's not going to this
reduction but but let's just focus on
this question so now we are focusing on
this question on pseudo randomness we
want to find some distribution that look
random for any constant depth circuit
but doesn't look random for a quantum
algorithm running in poly log time and
making even less than that's number of
forests in fact our algorithm would make
only one query to the hood okay so I I
want to define the advantage of a
distinguisher so let's say that I want
to distinguish between the left hand
side and the right hand side and we have
some algorithm a so I said that an
algorithm a distinguishes between the
two with advantage alpha if alpha is
exactly the difference between these two
expectation or the difference between
the probability that x equals one in the
probability that x equals one on sorry
on D or it equals one on
what is her main result we present the
distribution D such that there exists a
log and time quantum algorithm making
one query to the input the distinguish
between D nu with advantage at least one
over log okay so these are distribution
of our strings of length two M we also
show that any quasi-polynomial size
constant depth circuits can distinguish
between d nu with bad advantage which is
at most 1 over square root n there is a
gap between the the two this gives you
advantage which is 1 over log and this
gives you something which is much
smaller than that in fact you can even
amplify it via standard techniques so
you can make this advantage to be a
large constant as you want and you can
even make it close to 1 so you can make
it polynomial equals to 1 and this we do
sort of like afterwards yeah
it will be just more convenient for the
notation the rest of the so yeah now it
doesn't make sense why did I pick it to
him yeah I don't want to change okay and
once we have this we have the Oracle
suppression via these previous
reductions so my plan for this talk is
to first describe using this
distribution D well to show you very
briefly tell you why a quantum algorithm
works in distinguishing this
distribution from the uniform and then
the the hard part and most of the top
would go into showing the lower bounds
showing to show going to show that the
second bullet that constant depth
circuit cannot distinguish between these
two distributions okay so let's start
with the definition of the distribution
this is based on our zone 4 relation
distribution web first describe you some
Gaussian distribution and then I will
describe you some distribution over the
boolean screens
ok so again we have this capital N and
we think of it as a power of 2 and we
pick epsilon this is really some
parameters that will be more clear later
we pick it to be 1 over log n we take
some multivariate Gaussian distribution
over space of dimension 2 n with zero
means in covariance matrix which looks
like this
so it's a block matrix it's a 2n by 2n
matrix and I have a for n by n blocks so
the first block is just identity matrix
the second is the Hadamard matrix atom
out identity and I multiply everything
by Epsilon for some reason that is not
clear what is this polymer matrix it's a
fairly used a matrix all over the place
but especially in quantum
computing so this is simply the metrics
for the IJ entry equal to one over
square root n minus one to the inner
product of the binary representation of
I and J okay so we think of I and J is
numbers between 1 and n they have log
and beats and I'm just figuring of these
these bits representing vectors I'm
taking the inner product for this day ok
so this gives me some distribution of
her in get over the reals right of our
vectors and I want to sample some
distribution of our strings over vectors
over plus minus 1 to the N so the idea
is the first sample that according to G
and then it will be very convenient that
all the coordinates will be will between
minus 1 1 so what do I do
I simply truncate them if it's smaller
than minus 1 I take it to be exactly
minus 1 if it's between I don't do
anything if it's higher than 1 I pick I
replace it before so so now you see
exactly why I chose that song I chose
epsilon so that this would happen this
would change something with very small
probability perfect it does this will be
probability 1 over paulien ok so we can
sort of like forget about this
truncation it would not affect anything
and then basically we have numbers
between minus 1 and 1 so how should we
think of them we should think of them as
biases of coins and then just flip these
coins independently what do I mean by
that for each eye between 1:00 and 2:00
a.m. I have these numbers that I it's
just a number of you minus 1 1 so I will
pick Z prime I to be a plus minus 1
random variable
where's the expectation of Z prime I
should be exactly 0 what does it give me
so if this is the red I was 0 then I
flip a fair coin if it was a 1 I always
answer 1 if it was let's say 1/2
therefore bitty freak warriors I would
put on one 1/4 recruiter - this is and I
do it independent or coordinates ok so
this is a distribution I want to say a
different alternative way to define gene
which will be useful so this sort of I
didn't really tell you may be such a
distribution does not exist it not clear
I just tell you what the covariance
matrix so let's let me tell you a
different way to funny so you can sample
X 1 to X n to be Gaussian with mean 0
and variance epsilon and pick them
independently now and then take y1 to yn
to be simply the Hardiman matrix x and
that will be simply you know the
concatenation of x and y
so this is if you do this process then
you would get the viruses our epsilon
and the covariant says our epsilon
divided by square root n okay so now so
as I mentioned Scott came out with this
correlation distribution you can also so
the name for relation comes from
correlation of the full year so it's
like you applied you can think of them
it's like two parts of your input so if
you apply it the four year on on the
first part you would get something that
is correlated with the second and it
gives distribution with an algorithm
attend so with the distribution came and
I'll go with them this please this is
fairly simple I'll go with a meter yes
yes right so I want a distribution that
such that quantum who would catch the
heat but classical algorithms good notes
yes exactly
yeah so yeah so the distribution edge
was in order for this next guy to work
soft for this quantum algorithm to work
so if there is a fairly simple quantum
algorithm takes one query log in time
and accepts an input X comma Y so think
of now of the input is fixed and the
probability of versus the randomness of
you know quantum measurements the
probability that Q accepts is one plus V
of XY divided by two where fee is this
expression so summing over I sum over J
taking the Hadamard so this should look
familiar
x x i times watching
okay so what is this you can you can
think of it it's just so-now this is
this is a multi linear a polynomial of
degree 2 and we can sort of analyze what
is what is expectation is with respect
to the uniform distribution with respect
to the solutions that we just defined t
so what happens under the uniform
distribution to this expression we have
all these bits they are independent of
one another so in particular what
happens with respect to what the Army
was suggesting so each of these X I YJ
are uncorrelated and each of them are
like fair coin so so the expectation of
this monomial will be 0 and then we can
use linearity of expectation to say that
the expectation of this entire thing is
you what happens under the distribution
D so what is expectation of X I YJ it's
exactly this plus minus 1 to say you
know minus 1 to the IJ divided by square
root n may be times FC so basically the
plus minus 1 cancels with the
expectation here and we get a positive
sign for each one own monomial and let
me sum all of them up we have that
squared of them and we basically get
epsilon so it becomes very very simply
episode so ok so under Jesus would be
epsilon a but we are talking up over D
so we need to worry about this location
so it's almost obscene is a little bit
annoying
okay so what did we get we get a quantum
algorithm whose expectation under the
uniform distribution is half right
because it's 1 plus 0 over 2 and under
the solution D is something like 1 plus
epsilon over 2 so we get an advantage
epsilon and epsilon is 1 over log and as
promised so yeah so actually the
original suggestion of Scott was a
little bit different we we adapt we
change it a bit but mainly towards the
second part of the talk so a lot of
things that you would like play with
them would still work for this part not
sure about the second part
yes the Gaussian is well if you find it
with Gaussian but it's really really
important also that you would pick them
as biases of coins for the second part
toward so one things that so the parents
at Scott suggested was to just take the
gaussians and take the sign okay so this
would give you all Sola scriptura the
solution of a discrete object I don't
know to analyze
okay and second I can just very briefly
tell you how the quantum algorithm looks
like so basically you do the you have
only one query so what can you do
so you query a superposition of all
possible positions then you get the
answer you apply the hajima transform on
the left part and then you sort of
measure in the right basis and this
would fall out so this probability would
be the probability of fair getting a 0
and 1 minus this over 2 will be the
probably of cutting over
it's very fairly simple like few lines
of calculation not not something too
complicated but we are in our semester
on lower bounds I want to focus more on
the Lomo okay so so I want to tell you
more about why it's d pseudo-random
against a c0 circuit okay so these will
be the highlights in the proof so the
proof would use Fourier analysis I will
crucially use the fact that a since your
circuits are well approximated by sparse
low degree polynomials and this you
should put emphasis here on the sparse
this is very similar to what to the
notions that we had in cover stock okay
so this bound on the coefficient of sets
of size K so this would capture
sparseness
and then a crucial idea would be to use
the fractional PRG approach of Ch HL and
a very nice fact that we're gonna use is
the fact that some of got some of
independent Gaussian is a Gaussian by
itself and this would allow us to think
of this Gaussian distribution instead of
just one sample we'll think of them as
the sum of many samples and of very tiny
vectors and this will be very useful for
the analysis ok so this is just like a
teaser and that Caesar the actual
details of the proof ok so we are
talking about bounded depth circuits
just to make sure that we are on the
same page we are talking about circuits
where we have ends in or gates each one
it has unbounded Fanny will captured by
s the number of gates in the circuit and
by D is a depth or the length of the
longest path between input and output in
this case the depth would be considered
to be free because we have three days
output and the settings that we will
focus in is where the size is
quasi-polynomial so enter the poly log
and the depth is a constant the reason
that this is the setting that we are
interested in that this is what happens
when you simulate the polynomial ki by
AC zero circuit so basically you you
need to do because you do something like
to the Polo game this is like the size
of the circuit when you expand like so
you have there exists Y of flank poly
log and you go over all possibilities
for this Y so this is the size that you
would get all right so I see zero
circuits for something that we know and
love and such circuits with big numbers
oh it's not clear yes it's a good
question we would come to it yes so
currently yeah it just works with think
of it in the bouillon Naomi okay so what
do we know about X is zero circuits we
know that they cannot compute parity in
fact if they required size exponential
in n and to compute poverty and this
result was really motivated by giving a
conical separation showing that P space
is not in pH with respect to some okay
in fact this these results mentioned
this Orchestra portion in their title
and they introduced this notion of X is
zero in order to solve this problem so
it's not sort of yeah not super
surprising that when we talk about the
normal here we come back to AC zero
again and I want to mention one one
technique to prove this result that
party it's not nice is zero is it sort
of seem to be like the wrong technique
for it for our project but in the end it
will work so this technique is the free
analytical technique and basically so
based on a hosted result element shows
that s is your circuit can be well
approximated in l2 norm by low degree
polynomials over the reals okay this is
basically saying is that they know
something about the Fourier expansion of
this the other hand party cannot be well
approximated by low degree polynomials
if you have if you want to approximate
parity even slightly you need polynomial
of degree n so this show is the party
cannot be computed or even approximated
by loaded by sorry passing zero circuits
but what's the problem with this
approach the probe the potential problem
is it the the task that we are trying to
separate between them are tasks for
which quantum algorithm work right so
quantum are two little making
running in logarithmic time or
algorithmic time for making even a
constant number of courses and
importance in our case taking part in
any quantum algorithm such such as that
also gives you a low degree
approximation for any tasks that it
solves this test can be approximated by
a low degree polynomial so how can we
differ between the top
so there is a difference and the
difference is that although both models
are captured by low degree polynomials
these no degree poll numbers out of
different flavor so the quantum part can
be very sparse so a very dense and a c0
approximation is always spots okay so in
particular in the example that we had
before with a very low degree polynomial
P of degree 2 but if you look the number
of monomers is N squared
because almost almost maximum it's not
it doesn't seem that we can sort of like
approximated by a sparse however this
early result from four years ago is that
actually was motivated towards this
project we showed that a c0 is part of
the graph of summation so we can write
it in this form notation that if you
look at all the coefficients of sets of
size K and we take the sum of their
absolute value this is at most played up
raised to the K and you can also
translate it it into a result saying
that you have a low degree polynomial
with approximate your function and if
you look at how many coefficients you
have it's a safe level it's boy log to
the K so you can sort of a trim out all
the coefficients that are smaller than
some threshold and then you would have
at most boil to the K coefficient in the
K flavor okay but we will mostly use
this this bound and with this boundary
we thought we have a very
straightforward approach how to show
that you know the four relation is
pseudo random and that see this approach
and we'll see why it fails
okay so first attempt and by the name
you can guess how it will end up so we
are trying to okay so we are looking at
a boolean function we are expressing it
in the four year
basis okay so we are writing f of X
there's a sum over all subsets of the
coordinates we have a coefficient for
each subset times a monomial
so we basically write a boolean function
is a multi linear extension is a multi
linear polynomial okay what is nice
about this creature is it now we can
plug in values that are non boolean okay
so this is exactly we can even have a
nicer interpretation for this for
example if we plug in so remember that
the inputs that the boolean inputs are
plus and minus one what if we plug in
the all zeros vector then we get the amp
the empty for coefficient towards
expectation under the uniform
distribution if we plug any other vector
let's say that one to read to n you
think of them as number C like minus 1 1
to the 2 N and what we will get by multi
linearity we would get exactly the
expectation of F on a vector of
conflicts where these are the buses okay
so this is very related to how we define
the event distribution
okay
core what is our goal our goal is to
show the expectation of F ones that
prime was that prime example according
to D and this is a solution of our
boolean stream so there is no confusion
what this means is similar to the
expectation of F under the uniform
distance we want to show that like the
difference between the two is something
like 1 over square root n just using ok
I want to recall how did we sample Z
prime so we sample Z from g and g is
written there that we truncated we made
all the Z lies to be between minus 1 and
1 and then we sample independently for a
coins with these biases this gives me a
very nice way to rewrite this thing so
using multi linearity of F and the fact
that we are doing this process we can
show that this thing equals this thing
there's the expectation under D is the
same as expectation under G after
applying it's puncayshun and why is that
you can see it the de quacks for if even
if you fix the value of Zed fixing the
value of that you have this process for
you sample independently and then you
basically want to show that the
expectation is the same as the value of
the multi linear function on this vector
basically you can show it a one monomial
at a time and then use the linearity of
expectation for each monomial you just
use the fact that you know for
independent random variables the
expectation of the product is the
product of the expectations so that's
really just a manipulation so there is
there's really equality between the two
of them what else do we use so we want
to use the fact that Z is equal to the
truncation of that
probability recall that we pick the
parameter such that this would happen
and then basically we want to like move
from the truncation version to the will
like the actually okay so what does it
tell us he tells us that this
distribution this expectation is very
similar to this expectation so we can
sort of swap between them and just prove
that the expectation of F under G is
very similar to the expectation of F
under the uniform dissipation so this
this would be our goal now because we
are live the first attempt so something
would fail so we are doing the most
straightforward see we are just writing
there you know the fully expansion and
bounding it term by term bouncy this
difference term right there yeah so so
we are going here over all subsets we
have some coefficient for this subset we
have the expectation of the monomial
under G minus s location of the monomer
under you okay what happens to this
expression this becomes zero for most
monomials right this is a uniform
solution so this expectation would be
zero for almost all monomials except
except for the empty set and then for
that is that this would be one as well
so they would cancel each other out so
basically we are left with this guy only
for sets which are non empty
okay and now what are we gonna use we're
going to use the fact that these are
okay Gaussian with zero means and this
basically tells us that we can ignore
all the odd degree terms case of
gaussians with zero means all their odd
moments or zero this is a well known
fact about gaussians okay so now I'm
using some estimation on these moments
and I bound each of these monomials by
something like epsilon to the L times L
factorial divided by square root n to
the O so I'm using some formula on
gaussians in order to do that
that's what getting to the exact details
around
and now whether I have here I the sum of
absolute values of for a coefficient of
just of size 12 so I will plug in the
bounded that we mentioned before
when they hear that most polo and race
know too well what happens let's see
so for l equals 1 I get something like
PI log squared times epsilon times 1
over square root n this is exactly what
I wanted to prove okay so the l equals 1
gives me what I was aiming for l equals
2 seems to give me even something better
Polly logs to the 4 times epsilon
squared times 2 divided by n so even
divine nearby and so it's even better
however at some point so if I look at
the first square root n terms here the
contribution is epsilon times pi log
divided by square root n which is
exactly what I wanted however I don't
know how to handle the high coefficient
I don't know what to do when L is really
bigger than square root n and I think in
fact you can probably I think that you
can show for this specific distribution
that there are large set with not so
small coefficients
so somehow something else some other
argument should to the war if we believe
that state we discord so one way to try
solve it is to apply noise to the
distribution but there is a problem with
this approach is that it would also kill
the quantum algorithm so so we were
stuck on this for something like 4 years
and then after things is a very
beautiful paper on this fractional PR
G's we had this this new idea that made
us go all the way so I want to now state
the main technical lemma I want to sort
of obstruct what that what we are doing
so we could sort of like forget all the
parameters that we talked about so far
just focus on was written on this line
so let's say that Zed is some
multivariate gaussians on this dimension
with these two properties the viruses of
each each viable this most one over log
n recall why did we want that because we
want to be fight for basic the random
variable that to be within all the
corners to be within plus minus 1 this
ensure that that's the only reason
actually that we're gonna ask for that
we also ask that the covariances between
each two coordinates are small so we are
quantifying it by Delta and recall what
was Delta in our parameters this was
something like 1 over square root n
then any quasi-polynomial size concert
depth circuits else is following
distinguishability advantage the
advantage is at most delta x for Logan
okay
I must give credit to blossom Jarek they
give a very beautiful blog post on this
and they presented how like the
technical part in this language sauce
already this presentation is earning
their obstruction
I want to mention which properties of a
c0 circuits I'm using towards proving
this technical level the one thing that
I'm using is this is a bound once this
is a sum of absolute values of sets of
size 2 okay I'm using the bound that
sound of absolute value subsets of size
2 is it must boil login notice that I
have a bound for all for all K so for
all set sizes but I'm going to only use
this bond and the other thing that I'm
going to use is the fact that Isis your
circuits of certain size and certain
depth of clothes under restriction so if
I'm respecting I'm getting a circuit of
you of size which is at most s and def
which is a small T because of this
fairly simple property - sorry
in other words the proof could
generalize to any class a function that
has these two properties I will mention
this in it's a new direction and open
problems so you can you can ask whether
or not this this bond in particular
holds for larger classes of boolean
function in particular one that we are
we suspect and for which it will halt is
AC 0 circuits with parity gates so we
are not trying to get to a point in the
cube just might show that it's wrong
yeah but it will be roughly this so it
will not be too far from that
okay so basically we want balances to be
not too big and we want the curve answer
to be smooth
okay so what we'll be like in is idea
will be to view this Gaussian and a
sample is a result of a random walk okay
so instead of sampling Z according to G
at once we've got a sample T copies of
said that one of two 30 independently
and then take their sum so these are
vectors so we are taking the sum of
these vectors and divided by the square
root T if you'll check it will have the
same means and same variances as the
original set so basically this is just a
thought experiment okay so this is one
one one thing that is a bit different
hey what could I was talking about we
are using this random walk only as a 4th
experiment and another thing is that we
are not doing this polarization so we
are not like changing the step size we
are like always taking the same step
size and we sort of making the walk not
go for too long so that we would not go
outside the cube
okay so so this idea was based on this
recent paper of a shampoo you can check
out and you will see that we are every
using also a lemma that you could so you
should think of it as poly and this is
what I am writing in the next slide but
actually you can think of it as big as
you want you can think of it as a
Brownian motion we just didn't write it
in this line there is one things that
you need to to change but we already
wrote it and publish it online like over
the weekend so basically you can think
of T as large as you okay so so we are
trying to analyze this process and we
will use this random walk we will use a
hybrid argument in order to analyze it
okay so we will basically want to show
that so we have this starting point the
origin and we are making T steps each
step is pretty small we will show that
the value the expected value of F on H 0
is very similar to the expected value of
F on H 1
we will show it for each two of these
hybrid and this will basically give us
by triangle inequality the fact that
this is good one
so again we'll define H 0 to be the
origin for I between 1 and T will become
H I to be the sum over the first I that
divided by square root T and then we
will observe that HT is actually
distributed to curriculum to the
distribution that we are talking about G
if you take T to infinity this would
give you a Brownian motion what my talk
would not be in this language
so I'm just thinking of tears like poly
poly N and this would be
you know yeah probably we could have
picked event it'll be polygon but
therefore this is zero but maybe not in
this bond that only uses the second
okay
okay so in order to finish the proof we
just need to show that the expected
value of F on the I plus 1 I breathe is
very close to the expected value of F
and there is a IIP okay so just show
hybrid argument so we will show that
this is at most Delta over T times foil
again why is this enough when we are
summing this TI bridge we will get the
difference between the first and the
last is at most Delta over T times poi
log x T ok so Delta x point ok great so
this is the only things that we are left
to pull and let's look at the base case
the difference between H 0 and H 1 this
turns out to be very very similar to
what to our failed attempt okay so
basically what we're analyzing here
analyze the difference between expected
value of f 1 Z divided by square root T
minus the value of F on the all 0
vectors or the value of expected value
of F on the uniform distribution so
basically we can write the same
calculations that we did before like
expand the fully expansion right sake
let's do make for each coefficient the
main difference is that we you divide
each entry by square root T and think of
tiers is really huge so this gives you
obviously a lot but it does is it it
gives you like an extra factor of square
T to the 2 L for each coefficient of a
set of size 12
ok so this is about the expressions that
you get let's try to see what it gives
you four sets of size two so four sets
of size 2 you get l equals 1 so you get
here poly log you get l equals 1 so it's
delta times the constant divided by t ok
so you get Delta over T times pi log n
which is what we want square that we
announce to the other T is very big so
yeah yeah so I think pearcy with
interdigital and squirtin was the Delta
so that one over
yeah so square root n is not was not
enough but N or N squared would be
enough right so basically if we look at
the coefficient of sets of size four and
Beyond then this T really kills them off
and this should not be a super
surprising basically it's like applying
a lot of noise on a function when you
apply a lot of noise to a function
basically you make it a loaded vehicle
for lumia and then it's easy to fool it
so this is sort of what we we knew four
years ago so my idea was to sort of do
this many steps not doing only one step
okay so the next thing is to reduce a
general case to the base case we are
using this very and beautiful mo for the
h HL it's actually pretty simple to
prove this is that if you look at some
point we think of it as like where you
ended up after ie steps so that zero is
like pointing the is a cube and if I
probability it will be all the
coordinates will be between minus half
and half let's see so bombed it a little
bit bounded away from the edge and look
at the difference of F of Z plus Z zero
minus F of Z zero so apparently you can
write this it's a function of Z you can
write it as the expected value of a
random restrictions of the restricted
function on to Z minus the restriction
function on 0 basically you can you can
show that if around 0 when you take a
small step you don't change the value
very much want the restricted function
then around any point you don't check it
very much okay so the basic it's like
relating like the derivatives of the of
this multi linear polynomial at a
certain point to the derivatives of a
restriction at zero
and then to apply our best guess on on
the respected function okay so basically
once you have this lemma it's very
simple to use it you know it shows that
the difference between the I plus 1 I
bid and the I are pretty small so in
just condition on the value of the
highbreed and we condition on the fact
that also it falls within this smaller
cube fiction here okay
so the other one section will simply
want to move like so it's like what
table mention run so you have let's say
that you have this so you have this you
know you and now you are like here so
basically you want to look at this you
so you want to sort of shift this cube
to cube around 0 so then you take random
restriction so it's actually the random
section on depends on this it doesn't
depend on it's roughly the number of set
variables is going to be proportional to
the sum of the absolute values of the
coordinates
yeah you know so basically that tells
you the probability of flipping that
coordinate yeah yes
okay so now we want to measure the dish
the difference between the I plus 1 I
breathe and the I I breathe so the I
plus 1 I believe just the I I breathe
plus a small vector and then we are
using this lemma to relate these two
difference between is a restricted
function on 0 and a small vector and
then we use a base case and we use the
fact that F is closed under restriction
so but so this we use the base case on
airflow so this is actually the entire
proof yeah so it's a good
[Music]
yeah I'm like multiplying here by two so
here like right so here I'm taking that
and here I'm like multiplying by all the
vector like all the coin and sort of it
there's a very short few lines and maybe
you know today but okay it's an expected
that it's an exit but it's a very useful
man okay
libel Emma you syntactic rate since the
children don't so z0 is H I and
[Music]
it seems that syntactical dilemma does
not apply in this inequality so I so
very here you should think of like when
I'm computing it this difference
think of it is like I'm fixing the where
I am at after the I've step then I'm
sort of fixing a vector Z zero I'm
conditioning on the event that this
vector is also in lies between minus
half in half and then like you can
replace H I by Z zero in every place and
then it's only a function it's it's a
fashion on yonder Z on this Zi plus one
and you should replace this with
I mean pushing under the rod like okay
the fact that this happens if I believe
but what happens if it doesn't happen so
you need to sort of controls of this
case but at least like at the high level
this is what's going on
okay so it was there was a lot of text
on the slide so let's just do a proof by
picture like a recap of the proof by
beach so we did this random walk of many
tiny steps and then we use very simple
Fourier analysis to show that the value
of f changes by a small quantity when
you do the first step and this
remarkably only used the second level of
the four years and then we used this
limb of DHHL to relate between the I've
step and the first step so to say that
the almost the same but we need to make
sure that the functions are closed down
the restriction so we are going like
we're relating the I've stepped on the
original function with the first step on
their respective function okay so let's
recap what we did so far so we defined
the distribution over boolean strings
based on the multivariate Gaussian
solution G we showed that it was not
pseudo random again sequence quantum
algorithm running in logarithmic time
and making one query the main part of
the main contribution of our walk was to
show that this distribution is
pseudo-random against Isis your circuit
we had these four experiments of instead
of sampling Z at once we sort of did
this Jesus thought experiment will be
sample a lot of small tiny vector sum
them up and in order to analyze the
first step we use the fact that a c0
circuits are well approximated by sparse
low degree polynomials okay and in order
to reduce a general step to the first
step we use this lemma of fast eh
so this is almost all the details all
the interesting little going on from the
proof so I want to go now to open
questions so following up our results
Aronson in Fort now came up with an
oracle under which P equals to NP any
particular if P equals 20 cents you know
the polynomial if he collapses and
everything equals to P however big Q
piece has some things that cannot be
done so you must first separate bqp from
the phenomenology in order to have such
a result
it requires a little bit more than that
so basically you can say even if is the
unexpected world where the P equals to
MP and maybe quantum computer so quantum
computers would have still problems that
cannot be solved the efficient lance
also showed that under a correlation
Oracle pH is infinite this was known for
other of course but I think it's
interesting
Serco they cause some some open problems
so one is that we still haven't been
able to show that the original
suggestion of Scott works so the one
where we took the signs instead of
thinking of the devices of course and
another is to come up with new Oracle
separations that are sort of as a
prerequisite that have is a prerequisite
this bqp versus the edge separation so
so this basically are things that are
false for bpp and they think that they
might be Oracle's for which they hoped
for for pqp both these questions I want
to to mention a another open problems
that are already hinted so you can try
to you use this frame up two separate BQ
long time from AC zero with parity gates
and the only place where you need to
change the proof is that you need to
prove fully bound on IC 0 with parity
gate what did you what suffices for the
proof to work is that this is the sum of
coefficient of sets of size 2 is at most
square root n over poly log n we
conjecture actually the that the right
bound is much better than that we
configure the right button is something
like a poly log n correctly actually we
can prove something like squirtin times
40 log n so we were very close to the
border and we showed in this work with
each and puia in java we just posted
online we showed that if you can prove
this conjecture then you can sort of de
randomized agua the argument that i
showed you here and get an explicit PRG
based also on the polarizing random
walks
we've seed length poly log n fooling AC
0 with parity gates and just as a
comparisons in state-of-the-art seedling
for race is your authority gates is
something like n minus n over 4 log so
more than linear in
almost an so if you just prove this
small conductor you would approve from
an to
[Applause]
so it's kind of country to it that you
try this argument where the one in the
first attempt that failed but then you
just broke it into small parts and use
their triangle inequality which would be
worse and then it works so y-you have
some city for while
I mean I'm not sure I mean basically we
couldn't handle like the high
coefficients like we didn't know how
they behave one things that you can try
to do is sort of know cauchy-schwarz so
this works like under the uniform
distribution it doesn't work here is the
sum of squares of the distribution that
we were eating was I mean and some of
this yeah I mean it should have worked
I mean it's true also for this analysis
but when we sort of write it for logic
so the dependency on the error of the
PRG is baddies like polynomial in there
a parameter so in fact this PRG would
not imply strong correlation bonds just
yeah it depends
okay depends on how you optimistic so
yeah just to say again that we're in the
market for both shock communications and
for other problems so if you have kind
of a short talk to give about a recent
result contact been about it and it can
all be bound to present yeah email me
about it let's thank our again
[Applause]